en este vídeo quiero graficar la función
logaritmo en este plano cartesiano que
tengo aquí y también la función
exponencial las dos en este mismo plano
cartesiano para ver cómo están
relacionadas entre sí justo lo que
quiero hacer en este vídeo es comparar
estas dos funciones de una manera visual
así que en esta ocasión quiero trabajar
con la función quién es igual a 2
elevado a la equis ok y también quiero
trabajar con la función que es igual al
logaritmo al logaritmo en base 2 de x ok
quiero trabajar con estas dos funciones
hacer una tabla para cada una de ellas y
así poder graficar las las dos en este
plano cartesiano y entonces voy a poder
compararlas y entender de una manera
visual cómo están relacionadas estas dos
funciones pero antes me gustaría que lo
intentara por ti mismo así que te
encargo que pases este vídeo e intentes
hacerlo para ver a qué conclusión llegas
muy bien pues ahora que tengo estas dos
funciones aquí qué te parece si
empezamos con esta función de color
salmón vamos a trabajar con es igual a
12 la equis y para esto voy a hacer una
tabla así que déjame poner aquí una
tabla aquí tengo a x ok y aquí tengo ahí
ok y vamos a hacer una tabla así que
déjenme ponerle aquí la tabla
voy a hacer una recta por aquí ok y voy
a hacer otra recta por aquí ok y vamos
dándole algunos valores a x para ver qué
obtenemos de gemma así que qué te parece
si empezamos esta tabla con x igual a
menos 2 ok o espera déjame cambiar la
herramienta menos 2 ok menos 1 - 1
ok 0 0
ok y dos y por último tres y por último
tres ok y cuánto vale y bueno si te das
cuenta y déjenme ponerlo con este color
si yo digo que es igual a dos a la x
cuando x vale menos 2 bueno tendría 2
elevado al menos 202 elevado al menos 2
es lo mismo que uno entre dos lados y
esto es un cuarto estás de acuerdo esto
es un cuarto ok y si yo pongo menos uno
menos uno en lugar de x tengo dos
elevado a la menos uno y bueno eso es lo
mismo que un medio y si yo pongo cero
bueno dos elevado a la cero
eso es uno todo número elevado de acero
es uno excepto el cero claro está y si
yo sustituyó x por uno me quedaría 2 a
la 1 lo cual es 22 en la 2 los cuales
423 lo cual es 8 de lujo y bueno ya que
tengo esta tabla de aquí qué te parece
si ahora lo ponemos aquí en este plano
cartesiano dice cuando x vale 3 lleva de
8 así que estoy aquí en el 3 al quite
que me ponerlo con este mismo color
vale 8 es decir estoy como por acá ok
pongamos un punto cuando x vale 2 vale 4
ok
2 y 4 estoy más o menos por acá ok
1 y 2 a 1 y 2 estoy como por acá 0 y 1
ok es este punto de aquí y después
cuando vale menos 1 x llévale un medio
menos 1 en x que es este de aquí vale un
medio un medio es esté aquí ok y cuando
x vale menos 2 llevarle un cuarto un
cuarto está como por aquí ok y bueno
también podemos decir que cuando x vale
menos 3 va a valer un octavo y después
voy a ir pegando cada vez más y más y
más al eje de las x y bueno si ahora
unimos todos los puntos se va a ver más
o menos así se va a ver una gráfica más
o menos así déjame hacer algo más o
menos por aquí esta es la típica función
exponencial ok
casi todas las muchas exponenciales
tienen esta forma
las típicas funciones exponenciales y
después por acá va para acá
ok más o menos estos dos se unen y
después estos dos se unen más o menos
así ok y después esto se hace más o
menos así ok vamos a unir estos dos de
lujo y por último ahora tengo que llegar
hasta acá entonces estos se unen más o
menos a algo así y que de hecho estas
funciones exponenciales me gustan mucho
porque si te das cuenta empiezan a
crecer de una manera déjame ponerlo así
empiezan a crecer una manera muy lenta
muy lenta muy lenta muy lenta llegan a
este punto y de repente un bang hop
hasta que llegan es decir de una manera
rapidísima crecen y bueno esto sigue
creciendo y sigue creciendo sigue
creciendo y cabe mencionar que esta
gráfica de esta función exponencial se
va acercando al eje de las x cuando x se
va haciendo cada vez más negativa pero
nunca lo toca es decir que si yo pongo 2
elevado a la menos 1000 por ejemplo
bueno estamos en un valor muy pero muy
pero muy cerca al cero sería más o menos
como por aquí pero no tocamos nunca
el eje de las x está esta es la clásica
forma que tienen una función exponencial
ok déjame volver a ponerle bien algo más
o menos así ok
de 2 elevado a la equis de lujo bueno
esta función se acerca el eje de las x
cuando x es muy pero muy negativa y
después crece desmesuradamente de lujo
ahora pensemos en es igual a logaritmo
en base 2 de x y seguramente lo primero
que estás diciendo es oye sal eso se ve
bastante difícil cómo vamos a encontrar
la gráfica de esto pero recuerda que al
final esto es exactamente lo mismo es
exactamente lo mismo lo podemos ver con
un lenguaje equivalente que decir a qué
potencia tengo que elevar 2 para que me
dé el valor de x si yo quiero obtener el
valor de x a qué potencia tenga que
elevar a este 2 o dicho de otra manera
lo podemos ver como que dos elevado al
aire esto es exactamente lo mismo que x
2 elevado al aiem es lo mismo que x esto
es lo mismo que decir que ya es igual al
logaritmo envase 2 de xy si te das
cuenta en este momento lo único que
estoy haciendo de esta función acá es
intercambiar la x por la jem ahora tengo
2 elevado la i es igual a x mientras que
en un inicio tenía que es igual a 2
elevado a la x por lo tanto haciendo
este pequeño cambio es decir
intercambiando la x por la yema si te
das cuenta fue lo único que pasó
aquí abajo voy a hacer una tabla que me
sirva para en contra de los valores de
una manera mucho más sencilla de esta
función que tengo aquí es decir que si
yo pongo aquí a x a x y aquí voy a poner
dos pero esperar sino un signo de igual
y aquí voy a poner hay quien entonces
vamos a hacer una pequeña tabla y al
final creo que allá más o menos te estás
imaginando qué es lo que está pasando
porque lo único que estoy haciendo es
intercambiando la x por la que me estoy
intercambiando estas dos y eso es lo que
representa mi función logaritmo en base
2 de x así que si nosotros tomamos
algunos valores para x pero voy a tomar
algunos valores que sean fáciles de
obtener aquí con
me voy a tomar un cuarto o déjame
cambiar de herramienta un cuarto ok
también me voy a tomar un medio ok
también voy a tomar uno ok me voy a
tomar 2 4 y 8 y si te das cuenta como lo
estamos haciendo justo al revés entonces
estos valores me van a servir porque son
estos mismos y ya sé que es lo que me
tienen que dar
james o en este caso x lleva a hacer lo
contrario a esto o dicho de otra manera
que potencia toma ayer cuando x vale un
cuarto 2 elevada que potencia me da un
cuarto y bueno eso sabemos que es menos
2 entonces aquí me quedaría menos 2 ok
leamos de esta manera aquí potencia
tengo que elevar dos para que me dé un
medio bueno pues eso es menos 1 ok vamos
a ponerlo así el lugar y no en base 2 de
1 dicho de otra manera aquí potencias
tenemos que elevar el 2 para que me dé 1
bueno eso es 0 ok a qué potencia tenemos
que elevar el 2 para que me dé 2 esos 1
ok a qué potencia tenemos que elevar el
2 para que me dé 4 bueno
2 y por último a qué potencia tenemos
que elevar el 2 para que me dé 8 eso es
tres de lujo y bueno como este 8 está
muy pero muy pero muy pequeño
déjeme mejor hacerlo un poco más grande
ok de lujo y ahora ya que tenemos estos
datos y estos datos vamos a graficar los
justo aquí así que para eso déjame
utilizar el mismo color dice cuando x
vale un cuarto que vale menos dos cuando
x vale un cuarto es decir estamos como
por aquí que valen menos dos estamos
justo aquí en este punto de aquí cuando
x vale un medio que vale menos uno ok un
medio en x vale menos uno estaríamos
justo por aquí cuando x vale uno que
vale cero cuando x vale uno lleva al de
cero estamos en este punto de que cuando
x vale 2 de vale 1 2 y 1
ok cuando x vale 4 que vale 2 cuando x
vale 4 que vale 2 y hasta acá hasta acá
en el 8 que vale 3 1 2 3
ok es tenemos justo por aquí y bueno
también podemos ver que está esta
gráfica de aquí se vaya acercando al eje
de las íes pero nunca lo toca se va a ir
acercando el eje slayer es algo más o
menos como por aquí se va a ir acercando
se vaya acercando pero nunca lo toca y
después empieza a subir por acá
por acá espera esto va más o menos así
ok y si te das cuenta se parece mucho
mucho a la gráfica fue exponencial lo
único que cambia es que estas dos
funciones y bueno yo estoy seguro que ya
sospechaba sesto estas dos funciones se
parecen tanto que es un reflejo la una
de la otra pero seguramente te estás
preguntando bajo qué se están reflejando
si son dos funciones que se parecen
tanto bueno como es que estamos
reflejando a esta función para que me dé
esta y la respuesta es que se están
reflejando por medio de la función
identidad
si yo trazo aquí la función de identidad
entonces estas dos gráficas se están
reflejando la una a la otra es como si
pusiera un espejo en esta función
identidad y lo mismo que pasa de este
lado está pasando de este otro lado si
te das cuenta estas dos gráficas son
simétricas la una a la otra con respecto
a esta línea de igual a equis y esto
pasa y es lo más importante de este
vídeo esto pasa porque estas dos
funciones son funciones inversas
eso quiere decir que esta función es
inversa de la otra intercambiamos la
equis por la jep y la ye por la equis y
así obtenemos la otra función y
viceversa estas dos funciones son
inversas y es por eso que pasa que esta
función exponencial cuando la reflejamos
a través de la recta identidad llego a
la equis obtenemos esta gráfica la
función y es igual a logaritmo en base 2
de x 10 más lo puedes ver aquí cuando x
es más y más y más negativa entonces
esta gráfica exponencial se acerca al 0
y viceversa cuando en la función
logaritmo en base 2 de x lai es cada vez
más y más y más negativa entonces nos
vamos acercando al eje layes o dicho de
otra manera cuando x tiende a 0 la que
se vuelve cada vez más negativa y esto
sucede porque estas dos funciones son
funciones inversas y justo aquí lo
tenemos representado de una manera
visual cuando estamos viendo que esta
función es el reflejo de esta otra
función bajo
la recta de la equis estas dos gráficas
son simétricas bajo esta recta